taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey it tastes buddies it's the taste
buds podcast what's up buddies
i'm joe i'm sal do we acknowledge that
um
so the first episode uh the first couple
episodes has been released we
did a couple more so this is like the
new one this is the first time we're
together
since the podcast has been released yes
right yes do you want to do we want to
say that is that all right i think it's
fine maybe we
just because now we know some more
information and we could just address
some things head-on yeah yeah we
yeah when we started doing this we
didn't we just backed a few in in
anticipation yeah no pressure network is
live
we banked a few because we didn't want
any pressure
on our schedules and i mean that sounds
like i'm making a silly joke that's not
funny that's because
it isn't a joke and it's not funny it's
true right right i agree i agree yeah
it's uh we're in
we got taste buds pod now on twitter and
instagram
yeah at uh tastebuds pod on twitter and
instagram that
of course if you found this you know
that you're they already they already
here they're already
so yeah yeah and then yeah the youtube i
will tell you this
i was in heavy anticipation of this all
being released and it did not disappoint
because
the wave of text messages i received
upon the first episode dropping of oreos
versus chips ahoy
was was it was a joke it was a title
wave
and people's opinions are strong it was
a lot of uh
it was a lot of i want to read you a
text i got okay
for my good friend andrew youngblood
okay who
uh is the uh proprietor or one of the
proprietors
this entire episode because i got this
new thing and it's like uh
like it's like an adult sippy cup he's
got a place called the secret group in
houston
andrew youngblood i know has a place
called the secret group in houston it's
a great comedy spot
um check it out if you're ever in
houston but anyway he wrote to me about
oreos uh
chips ahoy is definitely a better cookie
i've given my son oreos two times in his
life
an hour or two later he puked them all
over the car
these are facts that can't be argued
with two different occasions with oreo
puke
cookies and cream puke that actually
sounds not bad it makes puke sound
palatable even
all right first of all i think that he
has to get his son to the doctor quick
because
the boys if the boy is rejecting oreo
then who knows what else is going to
surprise him in this in the tenure of
this boy's life if you want to call that
out i got text two
and i want to give you one i'll i'll
checkmate you because i got a great text
from the great bill burr uh-huh i hope
uh bill doesn't mind me uh saying this
but uh
i mean you brought it up so it's very
appropriate okay this is the opening
text no no
no other context i just know from this
where he stands right away
yeah okay what do you got
10 o'clock at night wednesday chips ahoy
is to cookies
what hot topic is to rock and roll so
there you have it and that's from a
brilliant mind okay that's my brilliant
mind
and then he just launched into stuff
that i think he
made such great points that he should be
a guest they saw a revenue stream and
they filled the void but there's no
heart in that
cookie there are easily 20 other brands
out there that make a better chocolate
chip cookie
forget about it forget about chip soy
chips ahoy is in the same category as cc
biggs for me
i think that's like a brand name i guess
that's like a that's what i don't know
yeah it tastes
mass-produced oreo cookie is iconic it's
america joe does not like america
okay so congrats you got that toxic
ginger on your shoulder
uh we let me tell you people
just before we start here we have
something queued up and we're excited we
have
yeah we have a new argument for today
obviously ready to go but we're not
gonna tell you just yet what it is
and then we're gonna we probably already
know what it is because it's probably
sitting in a title already but uh but it
doesn't matter
yeah i forgot there's titles uh yeah
we're learning but preamble
before we start i'm gonna tell you what
it's like to work
with sal volcano what and this
what is this what's it like this is why
chris chrissy d i hope you're overjoyed
yeah i am overwhelmed oh thank god
because i am and it would be weird if
you weren't sure of course i'm joy
you're one of my dearest friends in the
world
i'm very happy but i don't by the way
what am i being set up for here
somebody wrote on youtube they go oh buy
vacations together you mean he went on
your cruise
and it's like no we took vacations
together
it is weird to me that like people will
take the time to write
to write those things but uh anyways god
bless
so chris chrissy d of hey babe fame
yes our other podcast on that on the no
press
youtube channel slash network we we've
talked about
doing a potentially bringing eventually
bringing a third show to this network
so there's the combination of everybody
so there's you and chris
on hey baby oh yeah we thought maybe
even for the patreon members we might do
um
one-offs with the three of us called
like babes and buds or something like
that or like taste babes
but chris and i also talked about what
if we did we had chris and i did a show
so then there was a show of me and chris
so it was every combination of the show
and we wanted to do a show
that was just about you we're just
talking about you
[Music]
uh chris will frequently call me and go
i was thinking can't wait to hear what
this is he'll go he'll go i was thinking
about coming by
the shop on thursday to get a sandwich
joey rose is open now for business
sandwiches pop-up sandwich shop at the
stand to nyc 16th street
yeah wednesday to friday 12 to 4. eight
sand which is all eight bucks get a side
of chips
uh for a dollar you do oh a dollar i
knew there was something like that
oh dolly can't beat what is hey what is
it 1998 a dollar
there you go so he'll go maybe me and
sal can come by
together on thursday and get a sandwich
and i'll go i talked to sal already he's
got meetings all day on thursday and
then chris will go
enough with the meetings what is he
meaning about
and then we'll we'll launch into the the
the overkill
of meetings and why it's an overkill you
you think i want to i want to be in
these moments i'll just say i'll just
say chris i don't know what he's meaning
about i go
we we could write the show in five
minutes joe gatto
you go into a starbucks you throw up
blood
there you go that's a bit
well uh i mean i think you're really
diminishing what we do over there but
also
that's one eye you go into a classroom
you wet your pants there's a bed
what is all the meetings about
we need a meeting for every idea
oh i may be i got you know i got life
going on i know
i got meetings not i bet you only uh you
know maybe a half or
two-thirds of my meetings are
work-related personal meetings
right i shake personal emails i know
good things going on joe i'm sorry
i know i know i know i can't see you
know what i can't stand everybody just
like
hey let's get on a zoom let's do a zoom
let's go i used to be able to take a
call like in my car
or on the go and now like it's honestly
like
because we're like home and like you
know in this kind of environment
everybody just like thinks you're free
and everyone's always like well let's
just do it
so my days just get filled up with
goddamn meetings i don't want to take
them
the only zooms i ever want to do are
like drinking
zooms with a friend or you like with
your parents like a family zoom
any business forget it i don't want to
look at your business face
you know what i mean like i don't want
to well that's it now there's not even a
phone call i can't see you rolling your
eyes
assuming zoom is zoom is one step away
from bringing my feel unannounced
it's it's out don't do it it's
outrageous it's outrageous
a call on the go so not even like a
conference call like uh
in a room like just anyway so
today so
we're supposed to start god's gonna
bring this one because you gave me [ __ ]
about it
we were supposed to start recording day
at 12. you kept this thing on i hate
that goddamn thing
i like it i i i if it goes a little
askew
every time i watch the video three
minute clip or a 40 minute episode
i see it and i just get a freaking tip
it's okay
i'm gonna leave it it annoys me so we
were gonna start
today uh at 12 p.m uh and do some
episodes
yeah so i go to bed last night 10 p.m
so i can wake up bright eyed and bushy
town at like 8 a.m
and be like ready for the day i didn't
want to be rolling out of bed at like
10.
what time do you say 10 30. i went to
bed at 10 p.m last night i think that's
a little late i think
i think i think you went there earlier i
went and laid there because i talked to
you at 8 30 and you said i'm
going to bed right now 9 55 and you know
it
was it yes yes and i delayed you you
texted me and you said
listen if we can't talk right now i'm
going to bed i need a long night's rest
i was like all right i'll call you right
now i'm so sorry you gotta go off a bit
i hope you don't feel the pee under your
mattress
so he's in bed at 10 o'clock literally
like so i wake up like
i mean because i had a plan i don't want
to lay there for two hours
yeah i'm gonna lie there for two hours
looking at my ipad then i'm gonna get
eight hours sleep i'm gonna get up early
i'm gonna eat breakfast
i love it i love it right should i end
it up go ahead god god
so this is no no the scorning isn't hold
on hold on
it's only with the part that you gave me
[ __ ] for so i wake up 8 a.m
i'm ready to go uh our dear friend
homeless pimp
producer extraordinaire i get texts from
him 8 15.
sal needs to push the recording back to
1 30. i'm like
okay fine i go listen i said if it is
amenable to you if not no problem
okay that's fine that is what he said
that was not in pimp's task text i don't
blame pimp for that but you're on the
email
yeah well i didn't know the email came
through because pimp actually made it
sound like he only you had only emailed
him
but everything came to life which i
didn't care for you know but you have
the information now as you tell the
story you have the information i know
but let me just tell the story let me
just tell the story please so uh i go
okay no problem i go can we just start
can we just start at 1 30 since we're
starting 90 minutes late
pimp goes it's out of my hands i i can't
promise you i can get
set up it depends on when sal lets me
into the apartment which made it sound
like he was
standing outside since 9am
so i go okay sal sal texts me we good to
go today yeah we're good i go
i'll be at your place like 15 so we can
start at 1 30. so goes
cutting it a little close because i was
like i'll be ready at 1 30. like after
you guys signed off on it
every my schedule is to be ready for one
day okay so then he just drops out i'll
be there around one
no cause i thought cause i thought you
were getting here at one so we started
at 1 30. because i responded in the
email can we start at 1 30. he said yes
which meant can you put up the first
tripod at 1 30. but my whole point was
that i got to about 5 30 because i was
working
so if you guys came earlier i would have
to get up this is all
just build up to what i'm getting to
please i had no problem with any of this
yeah because i came to battle uh
something for another
i drove out leisurely yeah okay i
stopped it that's a whole nother topic
mexican restaurant you bought a new car
and it's been in the shop already but go
ahead
it's a whole nother topic as a matter of
fact you and chris
chris got a new car last week and died
on the side of the road they took it
back
you bought a new car last week it's in
the shop i got
listen so i got i so you're right but
let me just get to the store yeah what's
with all the car buying and the car
failing guys all the time with you i
might do a solo podcast and just talk
about you you could do it your
choices do the car show do the car show
listen
so i go it's all fine i go no problem
i'll be there at 1 30.
i'll i get here at 1 30. i go let's just
try to start at 2.
so it goes no problem we'll start at two
at
2 32 we're sitting on this couch
and sal for the tenth time has asked me
are you sure i should word the poll with
the and i just went like this i went
i just went sal
no but and at that that was the point
where i was like can we just start and
you said
you roll your eyes at me and the poll is
important i go i know
the political the wording of the poll is
important yeah
it cannot be understated how important
it is and this is maybe a little insight
that they don't see
but every week i draft the poll before
we start so i could just hit send and we
have a little
ted if you will right over how to what
to list first
because that's sometimes like sometimes
it's a clear favorite i think and
right and and you in and we said we're
setting up an underdog story right
but really there's a clear favorite and
so sometimes sometimes you don't want to
put
you know the banger you don't want to
put what's the better cookie oreo
because you know it's going to win and
chips sometimes you want to put chips
away first maybe give it a little nudge
right you know and also sometimes you
want to say like today's
for instance i think how very
appropriate
so there's a reason we brought up chips
away and oreo again because today's
argument is very similar it's the
chipwich
versus the classic ice cream sandwich
which resembles an oreo uh and the chip
which if you're unfamiliar
resembles the chips ahoy is it two
chocolate chip cookies with ice cream in
the middle yeah
however the twist is
[Laughter]
i am i am team classic ice cream
sandwich
your team chipwich that's right it's a
classic m night shyamalan
twist right here yes and but
here's the thing when i was writing the
poll
you threw classic in the ice cream
sandwich
and i agree i don't mind because we're
not supposed to curse
it said it on the internet it says
classic ice cream sandwich
i understand maybe maybe for the curse
we could do like i would do than the
other one we could do
maybe something from the uh the theme
song hey by the way a little shout out
to casey jones oh yeah
casey who created and wrote the taste
buds theme song for us that we
cannot stop singing over and over to the
point where
we might want to add some verses to it
right i i think it's great
look at this you got the klondike bar
okay you got a neopon let me let me
launch this because we're already 10
minutes in
so we wrote better ice cream treat and
since
classic is in the name of ice cream
sandwich and it's listed first
i was just like all right that's i think
a nudge in the ice cream sandwiches
direction
and if i may be so bold i think maybe
the ice cream sandwich
might be a favorite because i think it
is more nostalgic and popular
long term so then just listing chipwich
second as
simply two syllables and without all the
fanfare
i think i think sets me about 10 feet
behind you
starting line sounds like it sounds like
you're wasting debate points i'd save it
for the debate all right
all right so i'm gonna so i asked you if
i should not editing it now
you're not changing it i can i put
classic chipwich but you say
no who the hell says classic chipwitch
it sounds nice original chipwich no the
chip which you know and
it's like saying a classic creamsicle
all right it's like it's what it is
so the better ice cream treat and the
way i'm gonna put this bowl is
classic ice cream sandwich so they know
what you mean
as soon as your classic ice cream you're
like oh the brown cookies with the
the vanilla in between it's a one day
poll
three oh no i want to change the poland
don't know we just look at okay
i'm all good i'm good i'm sorry i'm
france
[Music]
you see what i mean you see you see what
i mean tweet us out
sweets out taste buddies all right all
right it's open
you want to start us off at why you
think for some reason a chipwich is
better
than the tradish ice cream
sand yeah uh all right well first let me
start by saying
not every time that we do these i'm i i
dislike
the other the other competitor and i
like an ice cream sandwich i really do
uh it's one of my favorite ice cream
treats if you will
that when you're not typically scooping
out ice cream like it's a treat
it's probably number two if not top
three whatever okay but against the
chipwich
i'm sorry what i think a lot of people
are gonna hold on to here is their
nostalgia
for the ice cream sandwich i think it
spans more decades but we could do a
little bit of research
as to when each one first hit the market
but i think what you're going to see
across the board is a more broad
nostalgia for the ice cream sandwich and
that's what i think is going to lend it
some of its
credence um but in hindsight if you
break down the ingredients and the bite
i think that the ice cream sandwich
while a perfectly simple combination
that does taste good cannot compete
now if you remember with now joe i mean
i just began
[Laughter]
if you remember the argument that we had
back versus in chip toy resort
i wasn't [ __ ] excuse me
crapping on the chocolate chip cookie
which i think
arguably is the best stand-alone cookie
i think it's the ultimate oh you were
just crapping on the grapes
chocolate which is the worst chocolate
chip cookie so
let's start let's check it out what
what's the ship's all at but what the
chip what does
chipwich does is it takes the the best
cookie ever made
not a chips ahoy but a chocolate chip
and it sandwiches it it's the concept of
an ice cream sandwich elevated
okay it's two chocolate chip cookies but
not to mention
the perimeter layer of chocolate chips
of semi-sweet chocolate chips
around the entire exterior it's one of
the main reasons i won't eat one
it is a taste explosion in your mouth
it is as nostalgic for me if not more
because when the ice cream truck came
there were many choices
and i'll tell you another thing you
would get one of these from the ice
cream truck
what are you talking about why wouldn't
why is that different why is the person
who
why is it why is the vendor who handles
mirror
frozen over rocket pop over
pac-man with the gumball eye over the
frog
over frog with the two gumballs with a
chocolate candy eye
joe if you're going to come to the table
right now don't embarrass yourself
listen you're just now you're misleading
all sorts of treats you're going to have
to hope good good humor you're going to
wrap up your preliminary argument
okay my point being is that i even have
it more nostalgic
like i think when an ice cream truck
pulls up you make a perfect point i
think the ice cream sandwich
while a staple and while an old faithful
is there's so many more exciting
ice cream treats out there that it's low
on the list and when people
glance up at that that menu i think
more people are going for chipwich than
a classic ice cream scam sandwich all
the time
and here's what i do too i'll just give
you a little insight into what i do
i don't open that plastic baggie right
away sometimes i even put the chipwich
in my pocket
i get a little body a natural body heat
surrounding the chip which it's just for
some reason that's really it's a
frozen puck joe and it's wrapped in
plastic
there's it's protected this is this i'm
just talking about a child i throw i
threw a chip
what i with you in my a little thigh
heat on that bad boy and what happens is
after a couple of moments
the perimeter that's dipped in the
chocolate chip it starts to melt but the
center
the center doesn't show okay what i do
is i then start taking bites
in concentric circles around getting
full
bites okay don't blow don't blow your
whole argument up top here
let me this is not close to my whole
argument okay let me
you gotta let me jump in you've made
like 800 points right now i gotta i
gotta
you should have the floor too when i'm
done with the fluid
first i wanna say that it's the bite
when i go around when it's like
40 melted these bites are amazing the
chocolate chip cookies have thawed the
ice cream is soft
you bite it and the chips by way of uh
physics
the ice cream the chips jut forward in
between the chocolate chip
and they kind of like it's almost like
an ice cream ejaculate in your mouth and
now that doesn't sound good
no but i tell you if you just take a
step
back nobody wants any ejaculate in their
mouth
but what i what i'm saying is it's more
like it's just great and then what
happens is that you get the chewiness of
the chocolate chip after the ice cream
explosion
and then you get the center is still
hard and what you do is you wait a
little more
and you're not losing the whole thing my
biggest gripe
ice cream sandwich hold on a second no
no no no no no hold on no no no that's
it
all right that's it for your points for
right now first of all
okay 1978 i was born in 76. this thing
is
1942. oh no that's the dear the guy was
born it was created in 1978.
okay so first of all i want to point out
how salvano likes to point out
the classicness of something and and the
old-school longevity of it
until it's a thing that he's arguing
against then all of a sudden the
longevity
is a negative number one number two i
want to point out
i never buy anything from an ice cream
truck that i can make on my countertop
in my kitchen that's number two okay
i mean you're sorry guys number three
hold on
highly relatable joe derozan your honor
your honor
please you're in your house like a stone
employee slapping the
three number three the chipwich
again another classic salvolcano
argument for
in favor of his food it has to be
altered
everything you love has to be altered it
has to go into his pocket and melt for a
little while
then he has to eat what don't you dare
eat it that's
altering it then he has to eat it to the
center then he has to leave it
so the center part can the way
it is chipwich here's my point the chip
which i'm
sorry that's it what are they saying
caught overruled it's taking
three foods i enjoy ice cream
chocolate chip cookies and chocolate
chips and
turning them into a teeth-breaking
willy wonka candy type thing like but
like it looks like if it's
my whole life stoppers look like the
gobstoppers looked like in the willy
wonka movie it looked like if you
bit it your teeth would shatter that's
what a chip which oh you mean
the one that they also call a jaw
breaker
what yeah that is the intent of the jaw
breaker this is something
that's causing everlasting creamy treat
have you ever bit one of those things
it's not soft
yeah that's why i told you i just that's
why i told you i take a spell
and i let the outer perimeter you gotta
put thigh heat on it to make it edible
it's not it's not a soft tree i said
sometimes i like to do it you know what
else in
the summer months a nice little nice
little solid ice on my thigh area
feels good i will now go to bat for the
traditional ice cream sandwich number
one
chocolate pure chocolate on the outside
in the form
that chocolate has never been found in
anywhere else you
that's devildogish the cookies
surrounding that ice cream sandwich
are their own thing they're their own
thing
okay uh the the clashing of the pure
fudge chocolate flavor against that
vanilla is
is incredible it's so simple it's so
good
ice cream sandwich right out of the
package
edible there is no you can get damn
right because you have
30 seconds to eat that son of a [ __ ] or
it's going to be uh
yeah by the way what you do you touch
that cookie you pick your finger up
that cookie it's not acting like fingers
but you bite it it shoots out the other
end no it never does
it never shoots out the other end you
know what it is it's like the room in
star wars where the walls are closing
the two chocolate chips the two
chocolate wafers are cl
from the second you hold it it's like
your hands are made of lasers
and the ice cream is dripping out it's
always a messy treat it's always a fight
against the clock you can't
savor it you can't enjoy it because it
melts too fast i think it's the strength
of the chip which
that it's so solid that you can take
your time and decide to eat it at your
own pace i have never had an ice cream
sandwich shoot at the back end you're
not doing it right number one
number two half the fun of an ice cream
sandwich is licking around the perimeter
licking the crack if you will around
what do you want guys you want one to
ejaculate anyway you want to lick the
crack of the other one
both are very delicious apparently uh
and right out of the package it is ready
to go and by the way
if you don't eat it in 30 seconds how
much time are you spending with an ice
cream sandwich
what are you doing it's not a steak i
don't know joe four minutes maybe five
five minutes or insane not 30 seconds
i don't want to open it and be like let
me get this down now it's an immediate
anxiety attack the second you peel the
layer
the second the guy hands you the ice
cream sandwich if i've i've never had
ice cream i've had i've never had ice
cream
last more than two and a half minutes
i'm saying in front of my if there if it
did there something was wrong
all right joe then i'm 90 seconds off
yeah
that's a lot of seconds in ice cream
it's like dog years it means a lot i'll
tell you another thing what they've done
to the ice cream
sandwich as of late disgraciah the
scratch
all right at least you feel that you're
getting something substantial with a
chip which you pluck it down two bucks
you're getting something that's about a
quarter pound what if they dug to it
okay have you pulled an ice cream
sandwich out of like a
a six or an eight pack from the
supermarket recently the thing is the
size
the the the the the precious oreo
klondike sandwich i know because they
can do everything with an oreo
ice cream sandwiches when i was younger
now they're called like jumbo ones
the jumbo ones are the regular sized
ones the ice cream
sandwich big ice cream sandwich got
together and they decided to slim those
down about
45 percent an ice cream sandwich is now
this slender
and this thing if you if you could
recall it all we were younger
those things were way more substantial
and i don't like it everyone did it i
always have had them like this
the picture on the right there with the
rectangle
i'm assuming are you just talking good
humor because here's another thing
there's a hundred different
brands that make ice cream sandwich
there's only one chip which baby
we're talk there's more than one chip
which i got news for you it might not be
called chipwich but plenty of people are
putting ice cream between cookies
you think chip would steal it i'm
talking about the chipwich
yeah i know you're talking about anybody
who makes
an ice cream sandwich do you see what
the difference no i'm not i'm talking
about the trade
there's it's the same thing with the
damn chip with there's tons of chipwich
brands that aren't called
the only ship which brand the only chip
which brand that keeps coming up is
flat out chipwich pimp prove me right on
this there is no way nobody else is
making a chipwich besides chipwich
this is the only tissue they patented
the name
you can't even search chippewa look at
that good humor chip
good humor good humor chocolate chip
chicken it's a chip witch though
but i'm battling you tall house nestle
uh whole house can get out because they
decided they don't want to put
chips around which there's the original
chip witch
oh you son of a [ __ ] you heard me
moments ago say that i wanted to put
the proper title the original chip which
it gives it a little bit more
gravitas all right well if you knew this
food so well you should know that the
box says that i
i don't need this garbage i'm doing it
and it i was roundly
rejecting i don't eat this garbage i
don't know that it would say that on the
box yeah i got news for you right now
i'm listening to this podcast just as we
do it
and you are not doing well by the way
since when is the residue on the fingers
bad you don't like cheetos fingers
either
is there anything better than licking
that [ __ ] brown stuff off your
fingers it's great
pimp what are you doing you shaking your
head like let me say sorry
he's reacting the way most of the
audience is going to you should know
that he's like
indicative of our audience and when he
recoiled in horror
when you mention that to him you don't
love cheese dust on your fingers you
don't like
cheeto fingers it's one of the things i
hate about it you don't like cheeto
fingers no
really no really you think i'm looking
in your eyes and lying to you
i don't want to ruin anything i might
touch
with processed cheese you're not ruining
it you lick your fingers
oh yeah that's what i want too i just
want to be just licking my freaking
germ digits listen shout i don't know
where you're eating these snacks at some
kind
i want to lick my body when i eat
something i don't know i want to lick
parts of my body i don't know what
governor's cotillion you're eating these
snacks at
i mean it's like you eat them on the
couch when you're depressed
it's like i mean it's disgusting
you lick your fingers that's part of it
the case you're making for an ice cream
you're bringing up something that people
are adverse to
to support the ice cream sandwich i'm
saying it's not a bad thing
what i would like you know what i would
like i would like to hold an ice cream
sandwich through the whole entire
uh meal of it and not get that on my
fingers
put some gloves on like this guy's doing
this and then you know what and you know
what with the cheetos
they had to invent the product these are
fingertips silicone
things that they invented finger covers
for cheetos
were invented because
you are a real piece of
slovenly not you you are a real
piece of slovenly [ __ ] if you
are buying finger covers for your
cheetos if you're that lazy
that you can't get up and just go wash
your hand when you're done well that's
another thing if you have
if you have an ice cream sandwich off
the truck or you get a pack of cheetos
out of bodega
and you lick your hands your hands are
never getting in the way
that chocolate wafer that [ __ ] stays on
you you can lick them
all day you're going to be doing this by
the way by the way i don't know how you
also i'll say this i don't know how you
eat your ice cream sandwich
you get a good humor you peel the paper
down as you go
and you don't get anything on your
fingers you peel like a banana you peel
the paper down
oh sorry according to you that's
altering
nothing all i did was say that i put the
food in my pocket or waited a moment for
it to melt
and you go just like every argument you
have you have to alter the food in order
to enjoy it and then you
and i say well that's not altering at
all joe it's just waiting to open it or
just choosing how i bite it and then you
say no it is and then in the next breath
you have the nerve to say
oh well the way you eat this so good you
have to peel it like a banana
it's designed to do it that way
because there's an issue if you don't if
you don't deal with chocolate fingers
you can do it that way
i do it that way sometimes and sometimes
i want chocolate fingers i'm not gonna
lie
i like to lick chocolate off my fingers
if that makes me wrong then i don't want
to be right
that's it i mean i don't know what else
to tell you you know what i love too you
touched on it
and by the way chipwich by the way i
didn't say this before you talked about
the chocolate chips on the outside
it's yet another thing that pokes and
prods and hurts your teeth
it's more hard [ __ ] on this sandwich now
shaking his head to agree with me
chocolate chips the chocolate chips
poke and prod and hurts your teeth
sticking out around the side of the
thing
okay guys i want you right now i want
you to tweet at tastebud spot i wanna
you have had the experience of your
teeth being prodded and hurt
as you enjoyed a chip which sound off i
want to see how i want to see the wave
of tweets we get about people like
i'd love to get a chipwich but it's the
prodding that keeps me away look at this
chip which hurts teeth
you can put it's ice cream that hurts
teeth all right
hold on hold on pimp google it's ice
cream google streaming
google uh chipwich hard to eat
take ice cream out though just just
write chipwich hard to eat no i know
let's just see what it says
let's see what it says the iconic
chipwich they called it iconic
you got classic i could have put iconic
hold on
what happened to the chip which it says
eleven you're not getting any it's
google
google dip i think chip was hard to eat
google brings back
zero research right i ice cream sandwich
fingers ice cream sandwich fingers yay
or nay
what do you what what do you think this
is ice cream sandwich fingers yayona.com
i don't know you never know look hold on
no go go to all though i want to see
what the
if there's blogs saying like you know we
hate it or we like it
ice cream oh ice cream finger sandwiches
that's not what we want
they flipped us all around here ah
forget it joe you're turning up a dead
end here i want to say something else
well neither came up which is good you
touched on this earlier right
uh you ever see like a bag of semi-sweet
morsels at the house maybe someone
intended to make uh you know a a
chocolate chip cookie or yeah
it's you know we have them in the house
here you know you probably have them
they're a standalone treat
well they're a standalone treat as my
point they are chocolate chips yeah
they're standalone treat
yeah they're more so steve i mean the
hershey kiss is a bigger version am i
right
okay chocolate chip cookie another
standalone treat vanilla ice cream
another standalone tree
i love all of them you touched on this
it's bringing three things together
and they amount to nearly better than
the sum of their parts
and i enjoy all three it's bringing
three powerhouses together it's like a
superband
it's like when soundgarden played with
people from stone temple pilots it's an
unbelievable thing
you don't see the ice cream wafer being
snacked on
sold or consumed alone because it can't
stand alone because it's a little wafer
that breaks apart immediately it gets
sticky on your hands and it needs the
ice cream
to be this is awesome that's a bad
argument and here's why
there's let me hit you on let me hit you
i want you to know every once in a while
my eyes jut over to mike just to read
his read the room
and uh again you're not doing well let
me tell you something
and i'll give you two arguments to to
two points you made
number one a peach is a standalone treat
green jello is a standalone treat cool
ranch doritos are a standalone treat
mixing them all together doesn't mean oh
it's even better now because it's three
becomes the the the the the sum is
always not
is always not greater than the parts is
my point sure it isn't she'll say that
so i think that it's not when the chip
which is uh sake
uh you know so in the case of the chip
which i don't agree that it's greater
number one number two
uh you said uh
uh the what was your other [ __ ]
what was your other point yeah well you
can't buy consume or purchase ice cream
chocolate wafers oh oh and i will say
this
because it is a special saying
that you can't get those uh on their own
because it's weak or it's this net
that's like making an argument against
the quarter pounder
and saying you couldn't eat that cheese
they put on it by itself it could never
stand on its own it's not about standing
on its own
it's not about deconstruction it's about
the thing as a whole
and this is something we always argue
about on here it's not about the parts
it's about the sum it's about the final
product
is the final product greater than
anything else that you put against it in
its own it's
in its own class and with this ice cream
sandwich it is
i don't i don't even think that your
argument right now makes sense that
defense makes perfect sense
you always do that you love to compare
stuff to other things but then the
metaphor
does not match up it makes you compare
the ice cream sandwich to a cheeseburger
and said
cheese doesn't stand alone on its own of
course it does no
no no no no that's not what i said
that's not what i said
i said that cheese it's like saying a
quarter
pounder sucks because you couldn't eat
that burger with nothing else on it
because it would
it wouldn't taste good it doesn't matter
it's the sum of the parts of the quarter
pounder that make the quarter pounder
great
okay let me ask you a question same
thing with the ice cream sandwich
uh buddy yeah yeah
but you you bring up the whopper and the
whopper is that no i brought up the quit
apparently quarter pounder is is
different
things put together to make something
greater than their parts is it not
that's very much like the chip but
that's what i'm saying about the ice
cream stand
but if you just but to give it a little
bit of merit if you break all the
components down the chip which they're
all standalone powerhouses
where your chocolate wafer is like a
little little cooling garbage
you're calling chocolate chips and
vanilla ice cream
stand-alone powerhouses are you vanilla
ice cream is not a standalone powerhouse
this might
be the single most popular treat in the
history of the world
oh well that didn't matter before with
the tradition behind the ice cream
chocolate chip cookie
and the vanilla ice cream are two of the
biggest powerhouses
in i agree with a chocolate chip cookie
i'll go so what's your way for god if
it's not sandwiched between
it's because of the way that ice cream
hits that chocolate wafer and the fact
that they invented a chocolate wafer
that meshes with that ice cream i don't
not like it i don't
disagree that they combine for something
great i don't think it's better than a
chip which
my point is you can break all the
components of the chipwich down and
individually they stand on their own you
can't even do that with an eye i can't
say
you cannot tell me i'm not gonna sit
here
i refuse to sit here
and entertain the idea of chocolate
chips
being a thing that stand on their own as
if they were like gum drops or jelly
beans you're wild
hershey kisses made a living chocolate
chips
it's different i'll tell you right now
you know what i do when i want a light
snack that's not gonna break the bank
the calorie bank
i get some dark sweet some dark
chocolate morsels in a bag
right i'd like a trader joe's and i'll
go and and what i want
i want a little sweet after dinner but i
don't want to go crazy i go i pour about
10 in my hand
i shake them up i eat them like they're
like pieces of duplicate that's a
total that's like what they are 80
calories total and a low amount of sugar
for like a quarter cup or whatever does
that sound like a fun treat mike
does not sound like a fun treat no
jersey kitchens are not chocolate chips
they're real
chocolate no they're not no they're
not real chocolate hershey kisses are
not like chocolate chips because they're
not
real chocolate are hershey kisses the
same as chocolate chips no
they're not real my point is
the hershey kiss is not the same as a
chocolate chip because the
hershey kiss is not real chocolate but
the the chocolate chip in essence
is a piece of chocolate so what you have
nobody three ingredients of vanilla ice
cream powerhouse
the chocolate chip cookie best chocolate
chip best cookie of all time
and chocolate okay gang chocolate chip
chicken
chocolate i'll ask you to write in write
in to us and tell me please if any of
you think that chocolate chips are a
snack
that you eat nobody thinks that that's
what you do when you go on the keto diet
and you're like i can't have real it's
not true sweets anymore that's not true
so i eat i eat dark chocolate 10
cacao
[Music]
then anyone who has made a house a home
snacks on chocolate chip morsels
it's only if you're some savage you know
something something some guy
i didn't say you can't snack on them
calling them a standalone powerhouse
that's insane you're putting these
things next to skittles
are you crazy they're a standalone
powerhouse because they're standalone
because they're just chocolate just like
a chocolate bar
they're real pieces of actual chocolate
i have never seen a guy go i've never
seen a guy go you know what never mind a
hershey bar i'm just gonna buy a pack of
chocolates
if you were in my house right now you're
like dude i don't know what it is it's
been six months but i am
dying for a piece of chocolate and i go
i can't help you out
and then later i go you know i have a
bag of chocolate chips downstairs would
you go
[ __ ] that's chocolate i would ask for
that it's not
chocolate i'm saying so to call it a
stand-alone pizza
because it's a piece of chocolate that's
nuts it's
literally that's chocolate perhaps more
than the chocolate chip cookie or the
ice cream you even call them semi-sweet
you're talking i said talk while they
come in all flavors i
i i also i also would make a case that
chocolate period chocolate
like don't bark up this tree because i
took chocolate in the chocolate vanilla
argument
and you took vanilla over ice cream and
you downplayed chocolate
over ice cream i'm talking about
chocolate
in its form better regular form yeah
better ice cream
but i would make i would make an
argument that chocolate in general like
a bar of chocolate
pick any brand you want is the
powerhouse over a chocolate cookie or
ice cream
i think chocolate universally globally
historically the word chocolate is
it's chocolate is addictive actually i i
think that is a powerhouse treat just
because it's in mortal form it doesn't
matter
it's addictive because it has caffeine
in it i'm not here for the who's in the
water
i mean jesus christ but i mean you know
where was all this chocolate talk when
you argued on behalf of vanilla ice
cream
this would be thrown out of court it's
not a good one it is a great argument
let's take it to the polls we're 40
minutes in we've argued this for 30
minutes
let's take it to the polls let's go i
will but i will say we have
it's our first one back in a couple in a
little bit i thought you would come with
something a little stronger are you
and i will say that if chipwich loses
it's not because my argument was not
more solid because i am
actually disappointed in you today
i promise you i turned people with the
quarter pounder argument
at the end i promise you that i also
promise you i turn people with the
chocolate chips
this is what this is inspiring me to do
pimp mark it down
this is making me want to maybe we'll do
it for our patreon subscribers we're
figuring it out as we go one of them
might be
the thing with all three of us but i'm
thinking is there a way to do
uh you brought up a live stream earlier
but like something where we can have
a live um stream where people are
messaging
as we go so we can see the temperature
and how our arguments are going with our
listeners
so when i when you say something like
you've turned people something egregious
like you've turned people with the
quarter pounder argument
if it was a live stream i can go right
to the boards to the live messaging and
you could tell me
you could shoot him down immediately at
that point i mean
i mean that's a two-way street babe i
don't know you're getting high on your
horse right now
let's take it to the polls let's see who
won
all right we ready for humble pie yeah
okay let's go
okay let's refresh this
and uh and pimp should get to do the
reveal
right gets to do the reveal sure pimp
you do the reveal
no i don't like that he gets to be in on
the final the reveal i don't care for
that
what the [ __ ] was that
yo alexa just that scared the shh that
scared the crap
out of me yeah why did she do that i i
alexa just
screamed she screamed she bellowed
her leading the first thing that came
out of her mouth was a bellow
she went no i was like
what just happened who's here and what
just happened in my home and then she
just went on and on
on a rant well well well
i'll tell you this is not good i'll tell
you why look at what we have
here this is not good i'll tell you so
it's very close i still love you
this is impossible how has there only
been 1100 votes which
stinks and you lost i see what happened
here when i write some business up top
when i go
let's go guys new taste buds recording
today with myself and joe derosa
better ice cream treat we yielded 1100
votes
when i just go better ice cream treat we
had 30 000 votes in the same amount of
time
so for some reason the algorithm is when
you put some business up top you don't
get more votes i say 1100 still a pretty
fair sample
i know but it's very close and i would
really prefer well
you know sal you win some you lose some
but it looks like
the old chipwich the i'm sorry i'm sorry
the classic chip which has lost
to the original 53 to 47 and i really do
feel if i type in better ice cream treat
only and i hit send in five minutes you
will lose this no that's not how this
works unfortunately
i i swear and you know what if we check
back in another episode
well we can i guarantee you that once
more votes come in that i will
let's let's read some of what the people
have to say let's read
okay uh that's what i thought
it was laughing my ass off and then some
comments made it
oh wait that's a reply i don't know what
that okay the chip which hurts my mouth
when i eat the chips
are too hard
all right well can i answer let me say
one ready classic ice cream sandwich all
the way baby
it's not called classic for nothing
that supports the argument i had up top
that said calling it the classic
was giving you an extra push i tell you
right now the words mean something
it didn't well i know they do do you
know what the word lost means
means you lost come on sal
classic ice cream sammy all the way
don't don't just
kind of argument is this chip which is
too decadent
yep what are we talking about since when
do i
since when do i do i throw the book at
decadence you can never beat a classic
they taste
so much better also the cookies are
never good
the chipwich is like two treats in one
agreed
all right uh i'm from scotland and i
haven't actually tried any of these but
i chose classic ice cream sandwich going
by a google
chipwich it looks too cookieish and
crunchy for me
chip witches never have quality cookies
chipwich no question there's nothing
like a chocolate chip cookie
add the ice cream and some mini
chocolate chips on the side for texture
there's no contest i agree the texture
is important
i'm getting multiple textures and layers
of texture in my mouth
you know i'm getting the chewiness of
the chocolate chip the creaminess of the
ice cream
and the snap of the chocolate chip i'm
getting it's so
layered yeah no i know that's it's a
shame the majority didn't feel that way
the uh i'm gonna give my vote for winner
we always pick a winner i gotta give my
vote
this i mean i usually we pick a funny
one but i gotta pick the the whoever
tweeted
this is my vote for a winner put you all
the way it's got crunch and flavor i'm
not eating bland ice cream stuff between
two pieces of chocolate flavored drywall
you win to me baby that's the winner
right we've got to give winners
we got to give winner to the guy that
said the chips hurt my teeth i mean
that's too perfect
it's too it's crazy that he said that
but i mean i'm not eating bland ice
cream stuff between two pizzas
chocolate flavored drywall is the is the
is the grouping of words i want you to
leave today's podcast with
because that is exactly what it is that
was my point exactly
it has no other purpose without the ice
cream
so you had your time to make your point
and your point didn't work
it's okay lose with some grace
you lost today you follow the judge out
of the court your honor i was going to
say this
too oh my god i want to know i want you
to know that these
listeners right now clearly you know
this you guys they have not heard our
arguments
and i'm telling you the things i say are
resonating with people
and that means it's really deep rooted
classic ice cream sandwich
as soon as it warms up in your fingers
it just starts disintegrating
and sticking to you chip which for life
the arguments of the ramblings of a
lunatic
ice cream sandwich because as soon as it
warms up it's not good
what the of course is it's ice cream
it's not supposed to warm up
you get you get the simple point he's
trying to make that simple meaning
the second you touch that thing it
starts melting and it's a race against
the clouds weird it's almost like it
acts like ice cream
instead of something that they
freeze-dried in the back of the delorean
and back to the future
all right savannah is our winner his
handle at
impractical sal this is a big fan of
yours
you did me dirty yeah the chip would
hurt my mouth when i eat it
the chips are too hard to be honest you
have a good name because that's
a practical opinion all right folks
that's our show uh plugs come out to the
joey rose's uh sandwich shop pop-up at
the stand in new york city in union
square come on out we're open
wednesday to friday 12 to four will be
dark probably over the holidays but come
back in
january when we when we re-pop up uh
because you probably won't hear this
before then
um joe derosa's comedy on twitter and
instagram
and uh that's it yeah you got we got
taste buds will be released every monday
you got hey babe releasing every
thursday uh
uh good to be back and um i just
i still love you i love you too taste
buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs